hey everybody its Jessie and today we're
going to finish our our load balancer
that we started yesterday and we got
everything working out but we just
needed to get it working with our SSL so
we're going to do that today and we're
going to use there's two different ways
to do that in digitalocean
and we're going to use the pass-through
technique so the traffic is going to be
encrypted even once it gets past the
load balancer since we already had SSL
setup that seems like it's going to be
the easiest way to do things you can
also do it a different way where your
SSL is set up at the level of the load
balancer and then that's where it gets
unencrypted and then it goes to your
servers that are behind the load
balancer so but we're going to do it the
first way I I'm getting I'm getting the
message here on the stream that the
streams not not great so let me know I
know there'll be a delay so I'm probably
back for about a minute but let me know
how this is coming through on your end
I am streaming from home again so if
you're with me yesterday you know my
network is not great I did lower the
settings so yesterday yesterday I had
kind of too ambitious settings hey
Sebastian so somebody is in the live
chat sebastian's and then he said hey so
I'm assuming that means he can hear me
sooner yesterday the settings were too
ambitious so I lowered them now so I'm
trying to get 720p normally I stream in
1080p but that's from work and the work
network is good
enough that I could probably do 2k and
it would be fine my home network I'm not
even sure I can get 720p yesterday the
recording I just checked the recording
earlier today and the highest that you
can even play it back is it 480 which is
not great so hopefully it's good enough
that you can see what I was doing but
not really great so hopefully next week
I'll be back in in the office and can
stream at my normal quality and
hopefully one day I can actually get
better internet at my house so I don't
know when that will happen but that'll
be awesome if it does so before we get
started I have a few questions for for
you all that are watching now live and
that will give everybody a chance to to
get in here if they're going to be a few
minutes late getting in before we get
started so yeah we only have about 22
viewers right now we usually have more
than that so okay Sebastian says that
the video does keep stopping sometimes
so that's the thing okay I've had a good
stream status for maybe like a minute
now so hopefully it'll it'll stay good
yet normally I am I do work from the
office I rarely work from home but okay
so it is it is lagging Mira says it's
lagging as well okay so I'm sorry about
that we'll try try to keep going if it
gets so bad that it's not you can't even
watch it at all just let me know maybe I
can try to and yeah I don't know what I
can do as far as the settings go you
know because I actually did lower them
from yesterday so it should be I mean it
should be a little better than it was
yesterday but if it's just terrible and
totally unwatchable I guess you know let
me know in the live chat and then maybe
I don't know maybe I can mess with the
settings a little bit and if worse comes
to worse I can just either postpone this
till next week or record it and then
upload it and then at least at least you
can all watch it at some point today but
it would just be recording I'd rather
not have to do that because I do like
being able to do the live chat so all
I'll give it a few more minutes just to
just to try to test it out here before
we try to change anything you just same
setting as yesterday keeps buffering hmm
alright let me go in let me check my
settings here hmm the only thing
all right let me I'm looking at my
settings right now Patrick says pause my
Torrance I don't don't have anything
going on in the background I'm gonna do
I'm going to do a speed test really
quick to see maybe maybe my Internet's
just slower than normal I mean it's the
same time of day as yesterday it ought
to be I mean also be comparable so this
once I get my my upload speed that
should maybe tell me what I should set
my my bitrate at it's not looking great
1.5 upload yeah I was getting twice as
much as that yesterday for upload but
still right now I only have my bitrate
set at 1500 so that should I guess it
should work
let's uh
I guess I can mess with my bitrate I'm
not I'm not super knowledgeable about
OBS I'm gonna bring this over actually
so you can you can see what I'm saying
hopefully assuming the video quality is
good enough for you to even see this so
these are my settings normally the
settings you know that I have this set a
lot higher but it should even with the
upload speed that I have from the test
that I just did the 1500 bit rate should
be okay and that's the minimum that you
need to stream 720p I can't change so as
far as the YouTube settings go I
actually can't go back and change the
the ingestion settings as far as the
like what I set the the bitrate at so
like I said it for 720p minimum 1500
kilobits per second so I can't change
that
hmm that said I'd have to actually end
this stream and start another one I'm
going to start another event so
yeah and I'm looking here at my my
stream status I'm not I'm not actually
hitting that 1,500 I'm coming close but
I'm not hitting that I'm definitely
under it okay I just I just popped up
over while now I hit 2,000 it's just
really it's lagging on 360 okay so in
the live chat I'm saying it's lagging on
360p yeah it's it's actually it's all
over the place I'm watching the stream
the status here you know on my machine
and I'm getting anywhere from 2,000
kilobits per second all the way down to
like 700 and I was 600 it's just
bouncing around like crazy
alright well at least before before I
change this or do something else let me
at least ask a few things that I did
want to ask you at the beginning here
and one is I got a new microphone and I
just set it up so I'd like to know if
this sounds better or worse than what I
had yesterday and what I normally have
so normally I just used the built-in mic
that's built into either the the iMac or
MacBook Pro but I did buy another mic it
just came in yesterday I set it up so it
was on sale it was pretty cheap so I
thought why not it had good reviews on
Amazon I thought you know it at the very
least it might be a little bit better
than what the built-in mic does so just
let me know it might be hard to tell
since the video quality is so the string
quality is so bad right now also I had I
had someone comment on the colors that I
was using saying is really hard on their
eyes so I at first I thought they were
talking about my my code editor but then
I realized after they posted an example
of something
that would be easier on the eyes that
the background color looked pretty much
exactly the same so I think maybe they
were talking about my terminal so I
switched it up so this is what I
normally have is black just completely
black background and I think that was
just the default dark theme that came
with item 2 so I changed it a little bit
and made the background more grey I
don't know if if anyone else has been
having that issue where that's been hard
on them hard on their eyes to see let me
know I don't have a problem keeping it
with this gray this actually matches a
little bit better with my code editor
anyway so I may just keep it like that
but I just wanted to know your thoughts
on that should I change it to something
totally different
is anybody else having issues with
seeing things the only other things I
wanted to do I had Oliver on Mensa on
Twitter requested that I just go over
the WordPress API just a little bit
about how I'm getting data from there so
I thought I might take a minute to do
that so we'll see but assuming this
stream is watchable I will do that
otherwise
maybe I'll just make a video and I also
had a comment this is last last question
I also had a comment yesterday saying
that I sounded a depressed so I wasn't
depressed but it may it got me thinking
maybe I sound depressed all the time
when I do videos and I don't want to
because I'd rather sound happy or at the
very least like neutral and not
depressed because I don't think it would
be enjoyable to listen to somebody who
sounded depressed the whole time so let
me know if it does seem like I sound
depressed alright so I'm getting some
feedback so it looks like Patrick and
Sebastian say the the mic sounds good so
awesome I mean I'm not I'm just talking
so I'm I'm not really expecting like you
know I need excellent quality sound I
mean maybe if I if I keep streaming and
I get you know
people watching at some point maybe I'll
get like an actual like a really good
mic but for now I think this is this is
fine I've really haven't had complaints
about the the audio quality and Patrick
also says plus 1 4 WP API so I think
I'll I will go over that then let's see
I'm gonna check out the stream stats
just to see what ok Sebastian says it is
cutting the sound occasionally but
that's probably a video problem also a
Sebastian also wants to know about the
WP API ok cool I didn't realize so many
people were interested in that I would
have would have done more with it so it
looks like most there are some people
that are getting a 720p stream it
doesn't it doesn't say how good that
stream is how much buffering but at
least the majority of people are
actually getting a 720p stream right now
some are actually getting like really
low like 240 I'm going to here's what
I'm going to do I'm going to attempt at
least to go over some WP API stuff and
I'm going to blow up the the text I'm
going to increase the font size as big
as I can ok Sebastian says the delay
delay for him is only about 5 to 10
seconds I can there was a setting I
wonder if I can get to it
there was a setting about whether I
would go for low latency or less
buffering and I almost I always pick low
latency so that there's less lag time
between what I am saying annoying and
and when you see it but maybe I should
if I can still do that I'm going to try
to switch that back to less buffering I
don't know if some of the settings are
locked in and you can't change the
after you've made the made the video
actually I can't change this so I'm
going to switch it up for less buffering
hopefully that makes a difference so
I've saved that I assumed that'll
that'll go a take effect immediately so
there may be more of a delay than normal
between what I say and do and and when
you see and hear that but hopefully that
will there'll be a little less buffering
okay
DAW says it's good for 720p Patrick went
down to 480p and it's buffering less
okay
so oh I'm sorry about that like I said
normally if you're just watching and you
haven't watched my earlier streams this
is an anomaly here I don't normally
stream from this location usually
there's no problem with the stream you
can stream @ 1080p and as long as your
connection is okay
it'll be fine today I'm just on a bad
connection so next week it'll be back to
normal
I'm just um I have a pink eye right now
I got it from my kids or conjunctivitis
whatever you want to call it and it's
very contagious so I don't want to
spread it around to my co-workers so
that's why I'm working from home so so
I'm fine to work I don't feel sick it's
just my eyes are really red and swollen
so anyway I should be fine by next week
and and everything should be back to
normal
so let me go over the the WordPress API
just very quickly probably just about
five minutes mears's says there's hardly
any buffering on 144 P but I feel like I
need new glasses yeah awesome so if you
wanted to to perform really well drop it
down to 144 p and and that should work
so alright but let me bring up I know I
already have open on on one of my tabs
one of my screens somewhere I have the
WordPress API stuff open to see it
alright so I'm going to bring this over
on this screen just so you can see this
is the output that I get from WordPress
in JSON format and let let me make this
as big as I can so this is the the
parsed version I mean this is really how
it comes just this big string here but
it's it's JSON data and you can see I
get this this is a custom post type that
I set up it's the major event custom
post type so basically I get the title I
get the content of the post here
including the HTML tags and then I have
some custom things coming in just from
some plugins that I did so one plug-in I
actually made myself and then the other
plugins I found that other people would
made to work with the WordPress API so I
get some extra data about my images that
I have attached to this this post and
just some extra fields I'm using the
advanced custom fields plug-in I get
some extra fields here that I added in
here so this is what it looks like I'll
show you in WordPress what I have going
on okay yeah let me show you it's not if
you have a newer version of WordPress so
let me show you really it's the plugins
that that matter so I'm not
I don't even have everything active yet
so I have some plugins that are for for
caching and things that I don't even
have activated yet but I will activate
it at some point but it used to be met
like a year ago if you wanted to use the
API you actually had to download a
plug-in to activate the API now it's
part of WordPress core so you don't if
you have WordPress and you've updated
and updated it anytime probably within
the last few months or so then you
already have the WordPress API it's
already working you don't have to do
anything to get it to work all you have
to do is go and I'll go back here just
briefly I know it's going to be hard to
see this so I'll read it out as much as
I can here this is just the address of
my wordpress site which in this case is
WP KDK Dexcom and then you type in slash
WP - JSON / WP / v2 and then you
probably don't you you may not have any
custom post types but you will just have
regular posts or pages so if you type in
slash posts then you'll get the list so
if you went into your browser right now
and you had a wordpress site running and
you typed in what I what I just said
then you would automatically get a list
of your post in JSON format so it's that
easy and in fact if if you don't have a
wordpress site running in you act you
typed in what I have here for this
WordPress site you would be able to see
it as well this is totally open it's you
know it's public publicly accessible so
it's it's super easy now I've customized
mine a bit so I'm using the advanced
custom fields plug-in to add some fields
to my post type so I've I've added in
some custom post types myself with and
that's the only plug-in that I did you
know completely custom it's the the to
actually make the custom post types I
did it in a plugin
and I can show that I'm lucky I wonder
if I have if I still have it up and I
haven't closed it out I'll show it looks
like I closed it out so maybe maybe I'll
just show a little bit of it but if the
quality is bad it's going to be hard to
read it anyway so when I when I get down
to that plugin maybe I'll show you a
little bit of code how I did it so
basically I'm using advanced custom
fields and then I have this extra plugin
to just expose those fields to the REST
API which is why I can see them in my
API I normally by default the API
doesn't give you the URL of the image it
just tells you hey here's an image and
here's the you know the number of the
image so it's not really that useful so
I have this better featured images that
gives me a lot of extra data about the
images and URLs for all the different
sizes of the image that exists so it's a
a lot more useful here's the the custom
plug-in that I made so let's let's go to
the editor screen on this just to show
you what it's like so making a plug-in
in WordPress yourself is super easy you
just pop this stuff at the beginning I
mean you got to have the you're p8 it's
it's all in PHP so you have to know a
little bit about PHP at least and you
just put this stuff at the beginning
just to name your plug-in a little
description and author name and then
here I actually I left this in comment
it out just as a template just to show
so if you want to do a custom post type
you just use the function create new
type and then you can set up all your
labels so these labels like this is how
it'll appear in the in the admin panel
okay so however you want it to display
that's how you you put it up just on the
back end in the admin panel for
WordPress and then these here are more
like what it will actually do
like what the slugs going to be how it
will show up on the API and and if
you're doing some other PHP code with it
you can tell it what it supports so what
fields you want it to be able to use of
the normal field so in this case I
wanted to use the title field I wanted
it to be able to use the the regular
editor the excerpt field and then the
thumbnail you can assign it taxonomy x'
and you can also do custom taxonomies if
you want so i actually did in this case
I had some custom taxonomies one name
brand one name body material options
this was I pulled this from another site
that I did I just copied the same
plug-in and changed I just edited it to
fit what I needed for this site you can
exclude from search if you want this one
you need it's a show and rest we do want
it to show up in the rest api so we hit
true ok we want it show up in the menu
as well so that's it and that's
basically you make a post down here
below you need to let me scroll down so
at the very end you need to add the
action ok so you need to create the new
type so you don't have to do it every
time you see I just put all these
together I lump them all together and
then I just did it once
I also did some taxonomy so I'm not
using custom taxonomies for this site
but I had them it was already in the
plug-in so I just left it in commented
out in case I in case I really you know
wanted to use it later on it would be
easy so this is how you do a taxonomy it
it's pretty similar you know you're just
setting you know here's how it's going
to display and you know here's some of
the values I want to show it and rest I
want to show it in the menu all here's
what the slug is going to be and so not
not terrible to do if if you if you see
it done once you can just copy and paste
and change the values and it's
it was super easy this is just a little
custom thing that I needed I didn't want
to display the normal title field in my
post my custom post I wanted it to be
different so this like automatically
changes that so but that's that's pretty
much it for that plug-in I'm going to
check the live chat just in case I've
totally lost somebody okay yeah no John
says buffering has stops on 720p so
that's awesome so maybe changing that
setting did help a bit ghetto Street
says not WordPress yeah this is not
going to be about WordPress I just
wanted to go over it quickly because I
had I had a request to go over the
WordPress API just really quickly some
of the other plugins I'm using that
makes this easier I'm using this filter
field WP REST API filter fields this
lets me return only the fields that I
want so I can make the the response the
JSON response that I get from WordPress
when I make that call is going to be a
lot smaller because I'm cutting out all
the things that I don't need I'm only
getting the data that I do need so
that's really useful pure taxonomy x'
this allows me to get normally you by
default you don't get a lot of
information about the taxonomy x' back
you just get the number of like the ID
number of that taxonomy which is not
that useful if you want the actual like
slugs for the taxonomy x' which is more
useful you can use this plug-in to get
to get that I'm talking about like if
you want the actual name of the tag
instead of just the number of that tag
or that category you can use that here's
the cash that I have when I activate
this the the rest api calls will be
cached so it doesn't actually have to go
to the database and get the information
to put together the
the json data once that's already been
done
it'll be cached and then that will be
ready so I'm going to do that I'm going
to edit the plug-in a little bit because
I wanted to
when WordPress gets updated I want to
automatically flush the cache so that
the people editing these posts don't
have to remember to flush the cache
themselves so other than that small edit
which on the github page for this
plug-in it actually walks you through
how to do that edit I'm basically just
going to use this plug-in as is I just
don't have it activated now because
there's still a lot of content being
added um
filter tools okay this just adds in when
I first started using the API some of
the the way you made an API call was
different and then they switched it and
I just didn't feel like learning the new
way so I downloaded this so that I could
keep using the old way so eventually
I'll learn the new way and I probably
won't use this but for now just save me
a little bit of time and this is
multiple post types so normally you need
to make one call one API call per post
type well that stinks because you don't
want to have to make another call but
also in in next which is what we're
using that's that's kind of what we use
to bootstrap our react project here
their default method of making API calls
and having that work with server-side
rendering only lets you make one API
call so you you want to only make one
I'm actually still working on trying to
figure out how to make multiple API
calls and make that work and I did I
read something recently that made me
think that it's possible but I haven't
been able to get it to work yet so this
this helps out because when I on pages
where I need to make multiple calls get
multiple post types I can get it there
so anyway so that's how I have it set up
you don't need any of these plugins to
make the API
work this just makes they all just make
it easier to work with the API and
easier to customize it you could you
could do all this yourself if you were
really good with PHP and with WordPress
and not use other people's plugins but
it saves me a lot of time because I'm
not I'm just a very like very much a
beginner with PHP so I don't I'm not
really confident that I could do all
that myself without it taking forever
all right so that's it for the wordpress
part of this hopefully whoever was
interested in the API I I gave you
enough here that you could you know get
started and work with it a little bit
let me know if you have any questions
I've been working with it for um at
least a year now maybe a little over a
year yeah actually it has been more like
a year and a half now that I've been
working with the API so not non-expert
but I definitely have some experience
with it I'll shoot so aim high says too
much buffering so it looks like the
stream is getting bad again let me check
the the status here
yeah it's definitely below yeah it's
it's getting the the problem it looks
like I'm looking at some of the data of
like what I'm outputting on my end and
it seems like the problem is it's just
fluctuating so much on average I'm it's
like a decent stream but it it drops
down really low and then it'll go up
really high back and forth so I'm I'm
really sorry about the stream what I'm
going to do at this point I mean we
actually don't even have that many
viewers so I'm assuming that probably
the stream is that bad that I'm just
losing people because this is way below
the normal amount of viewers that I have
so I think
sorry I was just reading the live chat
again
yeah the WordPress site is hosted on
digitalocean that the site that I just
showed you is on digitalocean so I'm
going to get rid of this stuff we don't
need that the the actual setting up of
the the load balancer is for the SSL is
going to be pretty simple I think we can
get through it pretty quickly
so all right since the streams getting
worse okay um if it's getting worse than
alright let me I think I'm gonna put
this up to a vote in the live chat
because I'm really I'm torn on this and
I can't see what you're seeing so I I'm
not really feeling how bad this stream
really is if it's that bad I'm gonna put
it up to a vote and I'm gonna give maybe
like three minutes or so before I make a
decision should I go through with
setting up this load balancer completely
with the SSO and everything even though
the the stream quality is pretty low or
should I shut down the stream and just
do it right now and make a video or
option three should I just wait and do
it next week whenever I'm at a better
connection okay so I have one one vote
here aim high says can we reset
reschedule the stream I can definitely
reschedule it I will have to reschedule
for next week because I won't be I won't
be able to get anywhere with the good
connection until until Monday so I know
there's there's going to be a delay
until everyone can respond to that
question so I'm just going to wait a
minute for for that I feel really bad
about this
I know I even I mentioned yesterday I
was going to do this we're going to set
up this load balance balancer so I'm
really sorry that this is not working
out the stream was not nearly this bad
yesterday okay Patrick says keep going
so we're splitting up
okay I'll give it just just a little bit
longer to see if anyone else responds
okay now it says the stream is getting
better see that's it's just it just
keeps going back and forth as being
really good and really bad I tell you
what I think I'm gonna go for it I'm
gonna try to get go through this and
then after I'm done I'll check out the
video and just see what the quality is
if the quality is terrible even on the
recording then maybe I'll just I'll
rerecord it or I'll do it
I'll go through it again like maybe when
I stream on Monday we'll take like the
first part of it and I'll just review
what what we did just kind of really
quickly and then that way you know maybe
there are some people that are getting a
decent stream so so let's go for it so
if you see here I'm in the basically the
same screen we left off at yesterday we
had I think we left off here actually so
here's our two our two droplets that we
had cloned and it's being we have the
load being balanced between these two
they're both up the only thing that I
did differently is I started the the
node server with p.m. - and on this one
it just started just straight out with
just the the regular server so basically
the only difference is this this is
being this process is being run by by
p.m. - it'll like Auto restart and
things like that so not really a big
deal and so no no really significant
changes so I have linked in the
description to this video kind of the
the digitalocean instructions for
setting up an SSL pass through on their
load balancers so if you want to follow
along with that or read some more
details as we're going then you know go
ahead and click that link I'm going to
keep it on my other screen so there'll
be more room to actually see you know
what I'm
but right now we were going past step
one we've already completed a lot of
these steps so I'm going to scroll down
all the way to let's go is step three
we've assigned okay so step three is
assigning the domain name to the load
balancer so we have assigned a sub
domain to the load balancer so it was
test Caddick addicts calm and yesterday
I think some people were able to go to
that and it worked I was not able to go
to that it didn't work for me I think it
was just a caching thing so if you go to
that and it works great I'm just I'm
going to assume that it works because
it's not really you just point the you
know the a record to to the domain name
of the load balancer so I'm going to go
back out to the the actual load balancer
here just to say so that's the domain
name that we pointed to so for me I'm
just going to go to that domain name
just to show like hey it's working still
just to verify that but you should also
be able to go to test dot katic addicts
calm and it should work like I said it's
not working for me
all right so now we I'm going to skip
step three just for a minute okay we
know that we're going to have to point
that a record of the main domain name so
just catechetical comm we're going to
have to point that soon but I'm going to
skip ahead a little bit
step four configuring nginx to use the
SSO so we've already configured this
before if you remember yesterday we just
commented out all the SSL stuff so to go
back in all we have to do is just take
out the comment tags which in free nginx
config it's just a hash tag so we just
need to take out those hash tags and
then it should work again we've already
copied over all the SSL configs from
that that original droplet that's live
right now in khattak addicts comm so
everything's set up so that's why I say
this is going to be actually pretty easy
because we don't even have to generate
new certificates or anything so almost
all the steps we don't need really the
only two steps we're going to have to to
worry about for this is I think step six
which is actually adding the SSL
pass-through rule to the load balancer
and then we are going to have to point
the the correct domain name so this
needs to be done quickly I don't want
the main site to be down for too long so
what I'm going to do first is
the first thing I'm going to do is
change the records so I'm going to bring
this over and this is our our second
droplet right now which we have we have
it running and I'm going to go in here
I'm going to go to that configuration
file that we edited and I'm going to
enable the SSL stuff again I'm going to
do this ahead of time now I'm doing the
steps out of order but I want there to
be as little downtime as possible so I'm
going to do this first and then I'm
going to switch the the domain name so
I'm going to go in okay Patrick said the
test domain worked briefly and then an
unexpected error occurred huh that's
interesting
I wonder what's going on with that's
just it's just really odd because
obviously the load balancer itself seems
to be working and I'm not even getting
it saying this site can't be reached
I'm getting an entirely different error
Patrick whenever you get that error is
it like basically a gray screen with
just some text right in the middle like
centered in the middle saying and
unexpected errors occurred okay it works
for Sebastian okay so does Patrick's and
unexpected errors occur it sounds like
it's the error that comes through when
when there's a problem with node like
there was some type of issue so yeah
refreshing it blinks the site and then
blows up Patrick can I ask a what
browser are you using and do you know
what version of that browser it is I'm
just I'm thinking maybe there is some
some issue with my site that I don't
know about I guess I should ask too if
you go to catechin x-com without the
test does that work for you Sebastian
says that error happened yesterday after
you
set it up alright so I'm not sure I'm
not sure what that area is let me um I'm
gonna go here on another browser and
just to see I just kind of wonder like
maybe one of the okay Patrick says never
mind you block origin was blocking
CloudFlare it works after white
listening it okay cool so hopefully we
that area is not an issue I guess we'll
find out so anyway so let me bring my
terminal back over and I know I said at
the beginning I talked about changing
the color but I guess the when I changed
the color it only applied to this one
tab so I'm not going to take the time to
change it again after fresh okay Patrick
is using Chrome it should definitely
work with Chrome
ok so I think it's going to be fine
think it'll work so I'm gonna do the I'm
actually gonna check the live chat from
yesterday I had it somewhere did I have
it here yeah I have it
okay so Oh actually I just saw this
right before I am right before I started
the stream so I just wanted to share
this with you all I'm not really looking
for work right now
but this came up when I was looking at
Stack Overflow on something and this
looks like an amazing job like the
salaries awesome its remote work or if
you want to go there it's in Florida
which was just a nice place to be all of
it just looks really basic like they
want basic HTML CSS JavaScript they
mentioned like jQuery in here really
simple stuff they use WordPress so
anyway check that out senior website
developer at Central reach they said
they're taking as long as you have like
two years experience there they're
taking that so anyway check that out I'm
not affiliated with them at all I just
saw that and thought that's a great
opportunity I would like to share with
you all so I'm gonna check here's the
live stream from yesterday so I actually
saved the live streams because I don't
always get to read everything and I want
to make sure that I see everything and
can can answer questions in case I
forgot so I'm going back here just
because there were a lot of good
commands that I use yesterday that I
want to use again today and
I think yeah it was it was something
like / you're not gonna I think my fines
not going to work for this command
because it's altogether
I was trying to get around having to
look up how to get to the config file
and I can't find it for some reason so I
will just go in here and try to remember
what it was I think I can so um sudo
nano um
TC and was it engine X yeah it was and
it was sites um enabled and then default
that's it
all right I should have should have more
confidence in myself that I remember
that so okay so here's our config file
so like I said I'm just going to go in
here and I'm going to take out all those
places where I I commented some things
out and then this should make it so that
it has the exact same setup as are our
main server which is what we want I'm
only going to do this for one of these
because we're going to we're going to
end up deleting the third droplet that
we set up because I'm only going to run
two so I so can say yeah we should be
good when we do these few last few lines
and then we should be good and I'm just
going to format that a little better
alright and that's it that's that's the
only thing we changed yesterday so to
get out of nano you hit control X and
then yes and yeah we want to rewrite
that all right so now we need to restart
nginx and that
I'll probably have to pseudo this sitio
[Music]
no I spelled it wrong
there we go okay
all right so now this should be set up
the way we want it to be able to use the
main address that we want with with our
SSL so these are we going to do I'm
going to say this out loud so I have it
right in my head the steps that we need
to take because I want them to all to go
really smoothly so we have minimal
downtime so what we're going to do then
is we need to remove we need to point
the main domain catechetical comm to
this IP address we need to remove the
load the the droplet 3 so I'm sorry I'm
getting distracted I've gotten calls
from my wife and now my my mother-in-law
so I just want to make sure everything's
all right let me my wife left a message
so I'm just going to listen to it well
while I'm doing this to make sure that
you know none of my kids are got hurt or
anything
and it sounds like I have like two
minutes of just random noise in the
background so alright it sounds like my
wife accidentally called me and then
left left a message
sounds like the baby's crying in the
background okay so I guess I'm assuming
that that's if that was a mistake and
then the same thing it seems like my
mother-in-law accidentally called me as
well and left a message that's an insane
coincidence so sorry about the
interruption but I was just worried that
I got two calls right then since I know
that my wife knows I'm streaming right
now alright so we're going to remove
this this droplet we're going to add our
original droplet so we'll have these two
and we need to set up the rules the past
three rules on our our load balancer
okay so let's do that so let me go here
let me log in I'm going to log in to our
domain name registrar so that we can
change where the main names pointing the
only good thing is for a lot of people
it's going to be cash so if we mess it
up some people won't even notice that we
messed it up because they'll still be
going you know pointing to a different
place so we should be okay at least for
a little it'll buy us some time
normally the the caching messes me up
because I can't tell whether I've done
something right or not but in this case
it may be helpful
okay so on my other screen I'm gonna do
the login and then I'll bring it over
know if anybody else uses UNAM for
hosting but their site just seems really
slow or not for hosting but for domains
I mean okay so here's what we need to do
all right hey Thor how's it going Thor
just joined us um yeah actually no I'm
not I'm not early he said that I'm
earlier he's late to a start time was
2:00 p.m. Eastern Standard Time so right
now it's 3:00 p.m. Eastern almost 3:00
so we actually haven't gotten through
that much yet we had some more technical
difficulties which basically just my
network is not really great right now
but we're at the point now where we're
going to point the main domain to our
load balancer and then we're going to
set up the rules for the SSL pass
through and hopefully it'll work so I'm
going to go here and copy I'm going to
copy this IP address and then I should
be the same IP address for this test and
that one but just on the off chance that
I had it wrong I wanted to copy the
original okay so I'm going to save that
hopefully I don't get you no calls and
messages immediately from people at work
saying the site's down what's going on
that actually happens really often when
I do something like this it's like 30
seconds after it's down somebody happens
to look at it all right so that's there
let's move we need to move our droplet
over let's add our original CI droplet
let's remove
this droplet okay great and why I see I
react down No
okay so for some reason that's down
maybe the move made it down briefly I
can I can go into there quickly if I
need to and see what's going on let me
at least set up these rules for now
because we still have one that that's up
and running so let's go actually a thing
I just need to go to settings alright
and if you're following along in the
documentation I believe we're on step 6
yes we're on step 6 okay so we need to
go to this forwarding rules and edit
those and we need to add a new rule for
HTTP and we need to pass 9 I need to not
a new certificate I need to pass through
there we go and we don't we want port
there we go HTTP should be port 443 I'm
going to save that rule ok
that's been updated and that should be
it that should be all we need to do so
let me check it out
all right so this is at least still
working although like I said there could
be some caching stuff so that may not be
the best test I do want to go back out
here to our droplets and see if we still
have one down
no and that actually came back up so the
down time must have just been temporary
due to the switch behind the load
balancer so what I want to do now is I
would like to purposely bring one of
these droplets down and make changes
also on one of the droplets that I don't
make on the other one just to kind of
get a test of like is the load balancing
really working are we going to have
downtime still so I want to see make
sure this works like like we wanted to
do where we have zero downtime even if
one goes down temporarily so let's come
over first test and let me go to this
original so here's the original I know
this is super small so let me make this
bigger
goodness alright alright so that's a bit
bigger probably can do do a little more
okay so I can do p.m. to stop next okay
so that should be stopped so since that
stopped if we go to catechetical comm
it's just still work I'm going to click
around normally if it stops I can get
maybe like 2 or 3 pages that have been
cached and with our service worker and
then the rest don't work so right now it
looks like it's ok I'm going to go in on
my other screen in an incognito window
and Chrome and try it here as well oh
it's not working there so we did get a
bad gateway so let's see might have an
issue
so it's giving us let me bring this over
I'm getting a 502 bad gateway error when
I try to visit this site from here let
me do a another refresh here
okay yeah it's it's still working here
but I'm assuming that this is some type
of caching thing that's making it still
work since I'm not getting you know
basically since I'm getting the error
okay and I'm starting to get some weird
stuff happening here okay so let's see
something's not working Thor says it's
working so are you are you saying the
site's working for you I do want to make
sure I don't know that these IP
adjusters will even work anymore since
they're behind the the load balancer all
right so I'm not sure what's going on
here with that IP address worked and it
shouldn't because I did just bring down
that that server I don't know why it's
still saying it's healthy to should not
be healthy what is going on
did I not bring that down it should be
stopped yeah yeah it's it it stops what
is going on
yeah this is okay so Thor mentions in
the live chat it seems like the load
balancing does act actually does not
recognize the 5:02 as unhealthy so that
was a thing yesterday we had we had
tested it out and it seemed like it was
recognizing the the bad gateway error as
the droplet actually being down but now
it seems like that's not the case so I'm
going to bring this back up I'm going to
bring this back up and see if I can get
rid of that error just to make sure that
this is possibly what we're doing now
but yeah look at this as soon as I
brought that up immediately it started
working again so yeah so this tells me
at least this hints to the fact that
maybe it is not recognizing that so what
I'm going to do now is I'm going to shut
down nginx so there's this droplet will
actually be completely offline it should
show up as being totally down so what's
the what's the command I'm gonna have to
look up the command for how to stop
nginx I assume it's just stopped yeah
okay so now we should be getting a
message that this is down I think it
does update automatically I shouldn't
have to refresh it but I was just in
patient and where they wanted to see
looks like something went wrong that's
not what I want to see networking
domains
hmm what happened
this is really weird because when I when
I go to networking I should get I should
get an option to go to load balancers so
this is really weird
who
de Rohan glad you could join us
Rohan just joined in the live chat and
said said I'm late okay so in case you
didn't catch what just happened here the
way to get to the the admin panel for
load balancing and digitalocean is to go
to networking and then there should be
an option to go to the load balancer so
you'll I'll show you here this is what
it should look like I should click
networking and then I should have this
here what's happened now is that I don't
have that it's not showing that at all
so I can't even get in to see what's
going on I'm gonna go I'm just gonna
switch try to figure out something here
now as far as I can tell it's still
running all right so it's still working
because we did shut down we did shut
down nginx on our main droplet but on
our secondary droplet it's still running
so both the node server and nginx are
still running so I'm just going to
verify that yeah it's still running so
it's probably directing everything to
there so it seems like it's still
working let me know in the live chat if
you tried to go there Khattak addicts
comm and if it's not working for you but
I am a little bit I'm going to leave
this up just in case we need to switch
back the the test doc addict addicts
calm
I don't know I mean that's still
pointing to a load balancer so me I
don't know what would happen if it went
that looks like you want to be topless
this is my own actually don't even have
any droplets going right now okay so I
went I've switched to my own account my
personal account and yeah so this is
what it's supposed to look like I don't
know why it didn't work so I'm going to
switch back to my work account and go to
networking there we go okay maybe it was
just some some glitch in the digital
ocean UI let's see I wonder if they
built this with this is actually react
so I don't know if you can see this it's
really small but this plugin shows me
with this built with so that's pretty
cool that this this in fact is a the
front-end is react very cool and it
looks like they use jQuery and react
together just like just like I did on
this site so I'm not the only one it
uses it even though it's probably better
not to all right so let's check out the
load balancers it says there's an issue
that's that's what I want to say here we
go and this should be down okay so
what's this is saying Eric connection
refused Sebastian says he got an error
connection refused when you try to go to
the site it's working for Thor for Julio
it's working uh and he's in Chile or how
do you actually pronounce Chile if you
live there is it is it chill a or I
think that's how you pronounce it I
don't want to be like mispronouncing
your country and being disrespectful
like that so let me know okay so
so it is chilly not chilly okay thank
you I thought it was I I remember when I
took a bunch of Spanish courses and we
would I'm pretty sure that's how it was
pronounced in those courses so sorry I
mispronounced that at first all right so
all right it's decides not working for
Rohan I wonder
okay Carlo says it's up in Brazil here's
what I'm wondering I don't know maybe
this is not possible
but if like let's say that the old IP
address is is cached as where the a
records should be pointing to then maybe
maybe that's causing an error so for
those of you who aren't able to get to
the site try this out go to type in this
IP address if I'm going to zoom in so
you can see it and I'm also going to say
it just in case you can't see this forty
5.50 5.1 19.1 42 because that should
regardless of any caching issues that
should take you directly to the load
balancer if that works for you then then
we should be good temporarily they'll
probably be some people who can't reach
the site until the until the caching has
run its course thanks Laura Thorpe that
the IP address on the live chat so you
can just copy and paste that and let me
know if that works it's actually super
helpful having so many of you testing
this out right here I mean otherwise it
would it would be nearly impossible for
me to get you know instantaneous
feedback from people all over the world
on whether or not this was working so so
this is awesome thank you
okay so Sebastian says the IP is
redirecting to Khattak addicts calm
which is giving an error for Rohan it
did work now alright um so but I I doubt
it's it's a browser error but on the off
chance that it is web browser are you
using Sebastian
and I'm going to try I'm just going to
try it out in some other browsers so my
other screen so this should be actually
I'll show you so I'm going to use opera
now and I set up the VPN to be like as
if it's coming from somewhere else so
I'm thinking that that should hopefully
get over any caching things as well just
to check it out okay so that's working
and I think I can set let's set it to
come from somewhere really far away from
where I am so let's try it from a
Singapore
okay so that's working cool it's
actually why they're not loading there
should be an image right there so I'm
not sure why it's not loading that image
because that's the wrong that's the
wrong URL oh I see what happened
I recently edited this image I optimized
it and so I needed to change the name
here and I guess I forgot that I had
been using media queries and had it in
those as well so I guess on certain
screen sizes that image isn't showing up
let me test that out by expanding it
maybe let me go to an interior page -
yeah okay - so it does work I just for
that particular page I forgot to change
it I'll have to make sure I change that
so I'm going to add that to my list
right now so don't forget it add it to
the to the Trello board
okay
okay so Sebastian said he tested on
Chrome an edge so I'm assuming it
doesn't work on either one Thor says
it's definitely a DNS cache error which
I'm hoping it's that because then that
means I didn't do anything wrong
and it'll just resolve itself with time
rohan says if he uses 4g and row on i'm
assuming that this is a he correct me if
if you're not a he but I'm assuming
Rohan this is a boy's name so so on 4G
it won't load but it works on the the
home broadband okay so yeah so this does
seem like I agree with Thor here it does
seem like a DNS thing since there
doesn't seem to be I mean it's it with
browsers and everything okay so Rohan is
in fact it's it's he feel awesome
sorry about that that's just not really
a common name where I'm from so just
wanted to be sure
I've only heard the name Rohan two other
times and one is from the the country in
Lord of the Rings and the other one is a
character's name in a cartoon Melissa
called Legend of Korra that I watched it
with my kids okay Sebastian asks he said
yesterday we set up a load balancer on
react to and react three but now it's on
CI react in C Iraq too and it does work
on Sebastian's fund okay so I'm going
with DNS error so I'll probably check it
again but only on 4G it works so what
we'll do is it won't really work for me
to keep checking it since it is working
for me I guess I could try it on my 4G
quickly just to see since I can't get
the error I won't be able to check but
what we can do is on Monday when I
stream on Monday then if any of you can
join me on Monday as well then
especially those of you who are having
the errors now we can see if you still
have the errors or if they work because
by the time Monday comes around if it
hasn't sorted itself out then I have to
look for a different different cause for
the error because it definitely should
have sorted itself out by then so right
now I'm checking on my phone on my 4G
network okay so it does work on my
network so there's really not any good
way that I know of for me to test this
error since I can't recreate it so it's
it's just going to have to wait I'm just
going to have to give it some time and
check it out
but anyway to answer Sebastien's going
to question confusion so yeah what we
did and let me go back to this just in
case you didn't you didn't catch what we
did you didn't see it maybe you're just
joining in a little bit later so
initially did we ever turn that back on
I don't think we did let me turn that
back on because there's no reason for
that to be down right I felt yeah we did
turn it back on maybe it just wasn't
showing up oh we turned off nginx I need
to start nginx again so
no I spelled it wrong didn't I
there we go okay so hopefully that will
come back on here in a minute
so what we did was for testing we were
using react the CI react to and then we
had a CI react three but we had gotten
to the point where I mean it's pretty
confident that the load balancer was
working we were able to go to the IP
address of the load balancer it worked
when one was down so that part was
working I couldn't really test very much
else out and that set up it was time to
test out the SSL so this is now set to
run this is the main droplet that was on
I honestly could have just used two and
three and not brought this in and left
out too it was just I would rather have
it be CI react in CI react to rather
than two and three so it's just kind of
a naming thing for me but it definitely
could have worked with the other ones I
didn't have to pull that one out so I
guess to be honest with you in hindsight
it may have been better to just set it
up on two and three redirect everything
and then that way at least if the DNS
was still going to the IP address for
this droplet it still would have worked
so that may have been a mistake on my
part I probably could have avoided some
downtime if I would have just kept it
going with the two and three I just it
was just slightly less work for me
because I wouldn't have to go in and
edit the config file for nginx for the
CI react three so so actually thanks for
asking that Sebastian because now after
I kind of talked through that I realized
that that that was a mistake I should
have left this one as is so that it
could handle any other requests coming
from if this this IP address was still
in the DNS cache so I could probably
move this out again and it would work I
wonder at this point if it's even worth
it because the cache should not last for
that much longer
Oh Patrick says he has a nephew named
Rohan
in my neck of the woods which is
Pittsburgh so yeah I'm actually really
close to Pittsburgh my wife and kids are
in Pittsburgh right now so really a
short drive depending on traffic takes
me maybe like a half an hour to get into
Pittsburgh from where I am so Rohan says
it's a common name here in India most
people from Europe or stateside call me
Ron okay cool I mean I'll probably call
you Rohan I don't have a problem with
that I like the name
oh okay Sebastian says now that I turn
enginex back on it does work so I want
to actually am really curious to see if
I can reach this site from the IP
address though and I can okay so I take
back what I just said about three
minutes ago I had thought that I've made
a mistake by doing this but it seems
like you actually still can reach this
droplet with the IP address for that so
I guess it works so I guess it would not
have made a difference and this was
still probably the most efficient way to
do it I mean really only saved me maybe
a minute and a half of work to do it
like this as opposed to keeping the
third one but yeah okay so we have them
both healthy now
what I need to remember to do though so
if you remember the original intent of
me doing this load balancing was to
avoid any downtime when I updated the
site because I had 30 to 45 seconds of
downtime whenever I was rebuilding the
react app so I wanted to avoid that
downtime so I figured if I set up load
balancing I could update one droplet and
then all the traffic could go to the
other droplet and then I would switch
droplets update like that the problem is
that the load balancer is not
recognizing when I take node down
because nginx is still running even
though it's giving an error it's
running so what I need to do is add
another step to my update process where
I actually shut down nginx
in addition to shutting down node that
is not really going to be a big deal
because I have all my commands chained
and I literally just copy and paste a
big chain of commands when it comes time
to update and I don't need to do
anything and then I will probably find
out a better way to update in time right
now I just haven't decided on anything
but I'm going to look through some of
the suggestions that I was given
yesterday and the live chat as well so
this should work out I just need to add
a step and I thought I think we've
accomplished what what I wanted to
accomplish and this actually did take
longer than expected but a lot of that
was just due to the technical
difficulties on my end and just kind of
more testing and making sure everything
was working all right so we've reached
the end I'm quickly going to go through
and check and see if there's any
questions in the live chat that I missed
I don't remember really seeing any
questions but you never know III
definitely could have missed it so at
this point if you were just here for the
setting up the load balancer and you
don't really care to stick around for
the questions thanks for watching and
I'll be back on Monday at 2 p.m. Eastern
Time
I'll post the topic on on Twitter
sometime on Monday to let you know what
I'll be working on then otherwise if you
have any questions put them in the live
chat now and I will I will answer if you
don't want to put your question in the
live chat you can put it in the comments
below the video and if you don't want
everybody to see your question just
direct message me on Twitter
my the link to my Twitter account is in
the description for this video okay so
I'm checking the live chat most of it at
the beginning is just you all helping me
to figure out if my
if my video was was any good if the
quality was any good looking through
this chat it's just crazy it's like a
wave between it's working it's not
working it's working it's not working so
sorry again for that I know I apologized
already but I do feel really bad the
shot really that much I could do about
it I can't I got a stream from home
today
okay so I've got through pretty much
pretty much everything in the live chat
now I'm just going down okay Sebastian
said he sent me a DM okay I'll check
that out as soon as the streams over
unless you want me to check it out now
and answer you on the stream let me know
Martin asks what is SSL so SSL secure
socket layer correct me if that's not
the right term so basically like when
you go to a website and it has the
little green like HTTPS with the lock on
it it has an SSL certificate all right
that basically it's showing that the
data is encrypted and I see some of you
are already answering Martin as well so
make sure you know check out the answers
here because there are a lot of very
knowledgeable people in the live chat
right now but yeah that's what you need
if you want your website to be encrypted
and to have HTTPS PS show up instead of
just regular HTTP you need an SSL
certificate I did do a video I think two
weeks ago where I set up an SSL
certificate so check that out it's when
I was setting up initially setting up
the servers if you want to know more
about how to set it up and I went
through how to set up a free SSL
certificate there are paid ones that you
can get
yeah Martin don't worry about it I asked
for questions so you can certainly look
out up if you want but I don't mind
answering it right now
yeah so yeah Martin so that's I mean
that's pretty much all I know about SSL
so I don't know any of the details about
like how the encryption works or
anything like that but if you have if
you're taking any type of user data like
in a forum or something or like
especially credit card data definitely
want to get an SSL I recommend having an
SSL on any site now because of search
engine optimization I Google search
engine ranking algorithm is always like
clouded in secrecy but we know that
having an SSO is a factor we don't know
how big of a factor it is but it could
you know potentially help your rankings
your search engine ranking so I
recommend it for that
I also recommend it for just in general
like confidence in browsers now you know
it's definitely very visible whether
site has an SSL or not so even if you're
not gathering user data your users are
going to feel better on your site I mean
not everybody but I certainly feel
better on sites that that I see have the
SSL especially because you can get an
SSL for free now it just almost seems
like you know if I go to the site where
there's not an SSL I wonder like why
didn't they take the time to do that
because it's so easy to set up now and
it's free you know you may as well just
do it so even if they're not gathering
my data it just does make me wonder like
it's such a small thing and it's so
common now like you know you think that
they would take a step you know that
just a little extra step to make you
feel more comfortable so I definitely
recommend it like if you're doing a
commercial site a hundred percent
recommend it but if if you can spare a
few extra you know minutes and really
depending on who you're hosting your
site with it can be as simple as just a
few minutes to set it up sometimes it
could be a little bit longer but I would
say
you know it's probably not going to take
any more than an hour to set it up even
if you're doing it for the first time
it's really it's really simple I will
say this though depending on who you
host your site with they may not allow
you to do the free SSL you may have to
pay for one I know I have some stuff
hosted on shared hosting with GoDaddy
and at least the last time I checked I
was not allowed to set up a free SSL
certificate but on other shared hosts
like SiteGround I am able to setup a
free SSL and they make it really easy I
just have to click a button and they
handle everything for me so it depends
on your hosts certainly if your hosting
with digitalocean you have full control
over your server you have you can set it
up it takes a little bit more work but
you can set up the free SSL let's see
I'm just checking the the chat again
yeah so Mark Martin and Thor are having
a little disagreement here I'm just I'm
just going to weigh in a little bit I
mean Thor III definitely I understand
where you're coming from
but at the same time I did ask for
questions so I'm not I'm not mad at all
at Martin for asking a question that may
seem to some people like kind of an easy
question because I mean I would always
just keep in mind like you don't you
don't know where people are at so it
seems like an easy question one person
may not at all seem like an easy
question to another person so especially
if you've never worked with SSL before
like you know a few years ago setting up
an SSL certificate was a really
difficult question to me now that I've
done it you know I don't know six maybe
six times maybe more on digital ocean
and done paid certificates and stuff it
doesn't seem like a big deal to me but
you know you just can't expect it this
is my opinion now
obviously I'm certainly open hearing
other opinions but I don't necessarily
think it's fair to expect people to know
whether or not a question is an easy
question or not
so definitely because I asked for
questions and the topic you know the
title of this video has the word SSL in
it so to ask a question like what is SSL
is definitely relevant to this so so
just so everybody knows I will take any
question pretty much on here and I'm not
going to get mad if you ask a question
that I've answered before or that seems
really simple it doesn't bother me at
all I used to teach high school so I'm
like almost positive I'm not going to
get a question here on this channel that
is that is worse than some of the
questions that I got when I taught high
school I mean I love my students but
occasionally you would just like get the
craziest stuff so that's my opinion you
know I'm not worried about it and Thor
I'm not trying to say that you're wrong
about it - you're certainly entitled to
your own opinion you might have your own
experiences with that so but at least on
this forum on my on my shows feel free
to ask whatever you want and I'll do my
best to answer it
Rohan says I know this is a this is from
a project but I'd love some regular back
end and maybe networking walkthrough
stuff there aren't many good quality
stuff out there and most of them are
really old all right cool that's good to
know I do have a list of topics that I
would like to make videos on probably
not live streams my live streams are
always just going to at least for now
they're going to be related to whatever
I'm working on that day because the idea
behind these streams were I want people
to see what my day-to-day work is like
because I think it'd be useful for
people who are interested in front-end
development or people who just like me
were kind of a lone to see what it's
like for other people to do their jobs
so
want to keep the livestreams like that
but I would love to do something like
pre-recorded videos of on specific
topics and have them be a little bit
more focused sometimes the streams can
be all over the place because I'm
answering questions and stuff so it's a
little bit scattered and I know that
probably is annoying to some people you
know they don't have a lot of time they
want to come to learn something specific
and then they hear me going on and on
about some totally different on the live
stream so I'd love to do some videos
that will be more focused and hopefully
a little bit shorter but more to the
point on specific things so I will add
your suggestions Rohan to that list I
just haven't got to making the videos
yet because I've been working so much on
this site now that it's actually
launched and I'm just kind of I still
have a long list of things that need to
be added and changes that need to be
made but I don't have to go it's quite
near the same pace so now I will be able
to start making some of those videos I
actually wanted to sort them this week
but then I couldn't go into work and at
home it's just way too noisy with all my
kids and everything the only reason I've
been able even do the streams is because
my wife has taken the kids somewhere
else during the stream time so I should
be back into the office next week and
should definitely be able to get some of
those videos made and those will be on
the list some some more back-end
networking things I'll have to do my
homework on it as well because that's
not what I normally do but I'll try to
do my best and I get you some good
information yeah good point Rohan I
didn't mention that CloudFlare Rohan
says CloudFlare and let's encrypt are
really easy and free for SSL so yeah so
for this particular project I used let's
encrypts to set it up and there are some
there's some really good documentation
from digitalocean on how to set that up
so if you just literally if you look up
and I think I link to this in some of my
previous videos about setting up a
server so you can check that or if you
search digitalocean
how to set up an SSL and then just put
like the name so if you're using nginx a
how to set up as a cell with nginx
using Apache say how to do with Apache
you'll find an article with it try to
find one of the newest one is and then
it'll take you through step by step it's
super easy I've been able to get a plus
scores for my SSL certificates just from
following some of the instructions on
digitalocean so yeah try that out don't
spend money on an SSL unless you really
have to because the free ones are are
certainly they do the job also
CloudFlare that would be even easier to
set up so check out CloudFlare you can
route your your name servers to
CloudFlare and then point them once
they're there CloudFlare then you can
point your your a records to your server
so all the traffic will go through
CloudFlare so between the client and
CloudFlare servers everything will be
encrypted and then you don't even have
to have an SSL on your own servers now
the traffic between CloudFlare servers
and your servers will be unencrypted if
you do it like that but at least from a
client's perspective it'll look like you
have everything encrypted and if you're
not really taking any data from the
client then that's that's certainly an
acceptable way to do it I wouldn't do it
like that if I was taking credit card
information but but that's definitely an
easy way to do it
okay cool it looks like Thor and Martin
have kind of come to maybe a little
agreement here and things have kind of
cooled down so I thanks thanks guys for
for working that out I like to see
everybody getting along because I mean
we're all just trying to learn and help
each other here anyway so I mean not
that arguments will arise I mean we're
all just Rogers people right we're not
perfect so arguments are going to happen
but I don't I don't want to see the live
chat for my shares turn into anything
that's kind of like aggressive and
people feel like they they can't be open
and asking things so this at least
should be a nice place for people who of
all skill levels to come and not feel
like they need to be ashamed of
what they know or don't know so Rohan's
now says I can learn the basics online
but there aren't really any intermediate
level stuff out there there's just basic
and over the top expert level stuff yeah
I definitely understand what you're
saying there it can be hard there's a
lot of basic stuff that's really easy
and and you feel accomplished you know
you do the the basic tutorials and then
yeah you're right there's stuff out
there that's just super hard to
understand in at eye level though how do
you get from one point to the other so
yeah I mean if if this if my stuff can
be kind of that intermediate thing
because honestly I would consider I
would consider myself to be entering
into that intermediate level you know
I've been doing this for a while you
know I've been making a making sites the
sites work you know I'm getting good
feedback from them so I'm definitely
past that beginner stage iving you know
I'm not in the you know tutorial level
of doing you know like code Academy
tutorials and stuff which there's
nothing wrong with those I did all the
code Academy tutorials and occasionally
I still go back to them if they do a new
one but you know I'm past that level but
I don't I'm not at the level of like
getting pool requests accepted into
major projects on github
and things like that and really like you
know doing some cutting edge you know
amazing stuff so hopefully I can you
know if there's not good resources for
that level out there hopefully this can
be a good resource I definitely want
this to be useful to people with if it's
not useful then I'll probably stop doing
it so if there's uh okay uh rhoann add
one more comment I think this will be
the last comment unless somebody else
says anything and then we'll wrap it up
Rowan says he's a student and can't
afford all the like the intermediate
courses that are usually too expensive
so I agree with you there I shine away
from the paid courses not that I don't
feel like they're valuable or I don't
want to can you know I'd love to
contribute to somebody who's putting
their time and effort into something
really useful you know so I'm not saying
don't pay for courses but for me like
you know I'm you know I got a family I
got four kids and a wife and everything
if I don't need to spend money on that
that means more money that can go
towards my family so and I'm not I'm not
wealthy at least by American standards
so yes I mean I'm always looking out for
the free stuff you know as long as it's
good so yeah my stuff I don't have any
plans to make any of my stuff paid at
any point
I mean maybe like maybe at some point if
I really want to do like some of those
affiliate link things that you see
people do I don't know but I don't have
any plans to make money off of this so
it's going to be free at least for the
you know foreseeable future I mean maybe
if I started doing this a lot like if
most of my day was taken up by this kind
of thing then it might make sense to do
some paid stuff but at this time you
know even if you don't have that much
money I'll I'll at least help you out as
much as I can
Martin mentions out of college for a
year and in the same place
with meaning like in that intermediate
level above the tutorial level can't get
a job called college 100% way CS
decrease don't anything yeah so I am I
also I don't have a computer science
degree I have a business degree so if I
think I mumbled that last thing a little
bit so Martin's comment was college 100
was 100 percent waste and CS degrees
don't do anything so I can't comment
directly on that because I don't have a
CS degree but I did it do you have a
business degree I will tell you I would
not have been able to get the job I have
now unless I had a degree it didn't have
to be a computer science degree but I
had to have some degree now I do work at
a university so they're a little bit at
a university everybody has to have a
degree right and I've actually had
opportunities and been asked if I was
interested in teaching this I can't
teach because I don't have my masters so
I can actually get hired to do this job
for the university but I can't be hired
to teach people how to do the same job
so I mean I think it has to do with
accreditation or something so I'm not
upset about it anything I'm not really
sure if I'd want to teach anyway but
there are some places that will require
a degree no matter what even if it if it
doesn't make any sense so in that sense
a degree is not necessarily a total
waste also I would say depending on the
program a computer science degree
wouldn't be a total waste there are
definitely some programs in call in
schools that are very prestigious and
the companies will see and they'll be
impressed that you got a degree from
that particular program like near me
there's Carnegie Mellon they have a
really good reputation I know the top
tech companies frequently hire people
from Carnegie Mellon both students and
professors from Carnegie Mellon so and
there are other schools like that you
know probably it throughout the you know
the United States is probably you know
also throughout the world so depending
on what field you're trying to get like
you're obviously trying to get a tech
job but you know if you want to get into
a specific field like if you wanted to
get into education you probably need a
degree
probably government as well they would
look more to degree so I just kind of
depends so I wouldn't I wouldn't say
it's a hundred percent of waste I I
would not go back and get a computer
science degree at this point the only
way I would I would see computer science
degree being of value to me right now is
if I wanted to teach I would go get my
master's in computer science so just it
does kind of depend what your goals are
and where you're at already but but it
would be more or less useful depending
on where you're at Roland says yeah I
mean last year degree was a total waste
so it's either stuff I already knew or
old stuff that nobody cares but having a
degree is very important in Asia okay
okay so Hardin says schools like that
are all about prestige and grades and
stuff I thought I would see students as
the stuff didn't appeal to me yeah
that's true to get into really
prestigious schools you do have to be
like really good with the grade so that
is not for everybody to get into so yeah
but I think the any degree can at least
be helpful because there are still some
companies some institutions out there
that will refuse to hire somebody
without at least a bachelor's degree so
that being said even if you got a degree
in anything it could still be helpful
now the nice thing about this field is
there's a lot of places that do hire
without a degree so if you don't have
the degree don't worry about it you can
probably still get a job if you do have
a degree then that gives you a little
bit more opportunity than the people
that don't so it's probably not a total
total waste but it's actually I'm
actually trying to address that at the
school I'm at
I'm working on setting up internships
for the computer science students to
work on these same projects that I'm
working on so they can get some
real-world experience and some things in
their portfolio because if you just go
through your computer science classes
and you don't do anything extra you
would have the degree but you wouldn't
necessarily have a nice portfolio and
that's what companies care about more I
think a lot of companies care more about
the what work have you actually done I
know where we're hiring a web developer
right now at my university and I'm
involved in the hiring process and I've
been sorting through resumes and for me
personally I don't care where the degree
is from at all I don't even look at that
part of the resume it is a requirement
yeah I think a degrees a requirement
there might be an exception for like if
you have a lot of experience you don't
necessarily need to have the four-year
degree but I don't even look at it what
I want to see is do you have a link to
your github profile if not automatically
I'm a little bit skeptical because I
think you know what one does this person
not even know what github is do I really
want to have them working here or two if
they do have a github but they don't
have any code on it or they're
embarrassed by the code and don't want
to tell me about it then what does that
say so work on definitely work on your
portfolio regardless of whether you're
in a computer science program or not
because that's going to be the the most
important thing
okay Martin says I'm probably going to
wrap this up soon because it's been a
really long stream so just a few more
comments Martin says grades are
nonsensical measure of absolutely
nothing as that's harsh
I mean that but you are right in a sense
I don't necessarily think grades are a
good indicator of your success on the
job all the time I know I have I have a
family member who I helped out a lot in
high school and in college to help him
get the grades enough to pass and like
it was just barely passing and he's had
no problem getting jobs right off the
bat you know getting jobs good jobs and
it's able to just move from job to job
getting better jobs and he's great at it
and he was never great at school I was I
graduated at the top of my class in
college where they call it assume summa
[ __ ] laude a so top of everything for six
months I couldn't find a job at all the
first job I got was a assistant manager
at a Burger King
it's a fast-food restaurant so and I
actually end up quitting that job in a
few months and taking a job as a waiter
at a restaurant because it was actually
better and I could make more money so I
definitely say yes like grades are not
necessarily a good indicator of your
ability to get a job or to do well at a
job so so I agree with that
Rowan says getting a BS degree this year
would love to get a masters degree
really only edge about actually getting
into it for it I would say row on it
just it depends on what you want to do
really for computer science related
stuff I don't think a master's is worth
it in terms of the time and the money it
takes to get it unless you have a job in
mind that you know needs that master's
so for instance teaching would
definitely need it or if you know
there's a company want to work for that
requires that so I would weigh that
that out because it's definitely you
know your time your your
all the money will take to pay for the
school but you're also losing out on the
money you would make during that same
amount of time assuming that you could
get a job so it's a big I mean it's a
big investment and a big sacrifice to go
for that master's degree so if that's
what you want and it's going to get you
to the place you want to go then go for
it but otherwise you know definitely you
know do the math on that and weigh that
before you make a decision on it yeah
Martin mentions shouldn't have to do the
extra work went to school to get a job
and I completed the steps yeah I think
that's like that's the big thing that
people are realizing now like I'm um I'm
31 and when I came up through like high
school
the idea was you know you go to college
you put in your time you get your degree
you get the job but then as I was
starting to get up like later in high
school and even into college um started
to realize that's not necessarily how it
works and then now since I've been out
of school what's getting even worse and
I think it's the case now that going to
college does not guarantee you a job
anymore maybe it did at some point in
the past but now that is not the case
you need to do you know you don't you
need to in addition to being in college
you need to have good internships and
you need to have good connections and
you know that's um that's just the way
it is I honestly think having good
connections is more important than
pretty much anything else if you're
doing computer science stuff having a
good portfolio and work is is probably
right up there maybe tied with your
connections but that's kind of the way
it is so if you're in school now if
you're thinking about going to school
going to college you know definitely
take that into consideration going
through college even if you're at the
top of your class it doesn't guarantee
you anything in terms of jobs
it definitely didn't help me
in terms of getting a job and you know
like I said I wouldn't have gotten this
job unless I had a degree but it didn't
really matter at all that what the
degree was or what I was you know it was
just like I had to have it so I'm gonna
check back in the live chat just keeps I
can't get to the end they're just more
keeps keeps coming so let me cut this
once we hit four o'clock I'm just going
to cut it off because that would have
been like that's a two-hour stream
that's pretty pretty long especially if
this ends up being low-quality I don't
want to have to have people suffer
through two hours of a low-quality
stream if they're going to watch this
replay somebody asks a sin since in your
case oh is that as is their playlist so
I can watch this project start to finish
yes there is on freako camp's channel
there is a playlist it's called live
coding with Jesse but the project
actually started on my own YouTube
channel so I link to that in the
description for this video so if you
want to start from the very beginning go
to my own youtube channel and start with
a video that's titled I think it's
titled building a website as fast as I
can
because when I first got this project it
was like hey can you do this project in
like six days I did get a little bit
extra time so that was good but start
with that video and I think there's two
videos on my channel and then I switched
over and got invited to to do live
streams on free code camp so now I've
been doing on free code camp since then
Martin Martin mention he says I'll never
get a job world is messed up martin noth
I definitely think you can get a job
don't get discouraged and I've been
there like I've been in your position in
terms of being out of school not being
able to find a job or being able to find
jobs that aren't good that aren't what I
want to do I've been there it's really
tough and not just when I was out of
school there was a time when I had a job
for a while and then I quit that job and
then I didn't have a job for a long time
and I was just taking little side jobs
doing websites here and there but we're
like low-paying type of stuff and it was
tough and at that point I had kids and
everything and then it was really tough
because it wasn't just me it was like I
felt like I was letting down my family
and my wife so I definitely can be
really tough when you can't find a job
but just you know don't give up and keep
trying you know you're going to get a
lot of rejection to keep applying to
places and keep working on things you
never know you know what'll lead to
something you know I had a connection
that you know my boss my current boss
now I had I had kind of known you know I
known him we had talked to you here and
there we you know we lived in the same
town but I actually got involved and we
were both involved in the same volunteer
organization before I got this job so we
had already kind of built up a
relationship and he knew he could trust
me you know that I was I was a
trustworthy person before I got this job
so that I think kind of helped things
because that's it's really hard to tell
from a resume whether somebody's trust
with you or not so you never know what
kind of connections will will help you
so you know just try to try to keep
going keep working on projects and you
know if you got to take some job that
you don't really want to do to pay the
bills you know go ahead and do it you
never know
it may help you out but just try not to
get discouraged I know it's easy for me
to say that it's but I've been there
before
so keep working through it you know
you'll get something check out the the
free code camp forums recently there's
been a lot of good posts about people
who have come through the same struggle
and have finally found something and
they talked about how they went about
doing that the things they did that
worked and didn't work so if you haven't
already checked out that forum and read
about some of that stuff I definitely
recommend it there's some inspiring
stuff in there and maybe may be helpful
to you someone asks and I'm sorry I
can't pronounce this name at all because
it's not in the normal alphabet that I
I know but is is Moscow State University
well known in the USA I can honestly say
that that sounds familiar like I've
maybe heard it before but I don't think
it's well known at least not to me in
the USA
Rohan says freelancing is great to make
portfolio mostly for web devs yeah
that's true that's how I built my
portfolio up was through freelancing I
like I had my own company kind of it so
I called it Jessie why go digital
marketing but in reality I was pretty
much a freelancer so I was able to make
a lot of good connections and improve
with real work that I got paid for that
I could do what you know that could do
this job so that really did help when I
got the job that I currently have now
was being able to show my portfolio and
what I'd done and when I was
interviewing being able to reference you
know hey I had this client before and we
worked on this project and this is how
he handled it because I did get
questions about you know how did you how
would you handle this if this happened
and I was able to say well this actually
did happen to me when I was working on
this project and I could talk about what
I did so you know freelancing is not
freelancing was really tough like oh my
family especially on my wife it you know
she worried about it because you don't
have guaranteed income you know one
month you're doing well the next month
you know you can barely buy any
groceries you know so it's tough but in
that in that sense and it's tough
because you have to market yourself to
people and I never liked that part of
the job at all but but it can definitely
be a way to get nice a nice experience
and get paid
okay Kenya says I'm a mathematician I
found out that there's more work as a
developer than mathematician unless it's
in big data and stuff so I started free
code camp and it's really good
awesome yeah I'm glad that you like free
code camp stuff so I did free code camp
stuff and I definitely yeah I definitely
recommend that I'm actually I never
finished my free code camp like all the
certifications you can get I really want
to go back and do that at some point
it's just it's hard to justify taking
time to do that what I could be doing
work that I'm getting paid for so I
still really want to do it someday
because I you know I just like free code
camp so much it'd be great to be able to
have a post one day and say hey look
here's my certificate I think that would
be cool
yeah Kenya uh it's hard I feel very
nervous and anxious to find a job I I
know how you feel um yeah that
nervousness is um that's tough it's
tough to get over it's hard to put
yourself out there you know and take the
chance and then get disappointed with
things so just keep on trying you know
it gets easier the more you try to do it
it'll get easier and even uh you know if
you can't try to do something uh like
this like I am you know live stream a
YouTube video or like a meet-up or
something like that where you can get
out there with other people and it will
help you feel a little bit more
comfortable
I was super kind of paranoid about other
people seeing my code I thought like
people will see my code and they'll like
you know think it's terrible and then
like they'll tell my boss there are
employers that my code is terrible and
then like I just had kind of this
irrational fear of that and I remember
about a year ago I was at a conference
and someone told me I had kind of
mentioned my my fear of this because I
was even afraid to put my code on github
I had stuff on github but it was in like
private repositories and they you know
they said I don't you know don't worry
about it just you know put yourself out
there and most people are going to be
helpful and so what if some people were
mean about it you know just you know
don't don't be afraid to do that and I
didn't act on that right away but I
stayed in my mind and and they're not
being really helpful advice and I
actually I don't even remember the name
of the person that told me that I wish I
did but I'm really glad that they they
did tell me that and that helped and
then now you know a year later not only
do I have stuff on github but I'm live
coding you know on YouTube which you
know it's kind of I guess even more of a
scary situation because people can
immediately tell me hey you're doing
terrible stuff that's never happened but
it's been remarkably positive feedback
for me and it's
it's helped me to get better but yeah I
just the only way to get over the
nervousness is just to get yourself out
there and and just kind of face it
awesome
rohan says really good talking here um
Tony since I have si and usually don't
talk too much in chat so I feel good
here I'm sorry what's si I'm blanking
here what's that an abbreviation for
situational anxiety is that maybe I'm
not maybe that's it I don't know we'll
see actually I am I definitely
understand I have a son my oldest son
has obsessive-compulsive disorder and
has a lot of anxiety and so I have a lot
of sympathy if anybody struggling with
stuff like that
I know it can be just super super hard
and I know - I'm usually not it probably
sounds weird because I'm doing stuff on
YouTube now but I like never talk on you
know online forms or chats and things
like this I'm always like just kind of
staying in the background but now that
I'm doing more like this I just I wish I
would have started sooner
okay Rowland says I guess we should
start a discord server so or an IRC yeah
whatever
whatever you all think would be the best
way to do this to have a chat it would
be kind of cool to have some sort of
group to chat where it's you know it
doesn't have to be just during the the
livestream so let me know what you all
decide and so I can I can join up
okay so Thor says freako camp already
does have a gator thing yeah that's true
I forgot about that they do have get her
okay
Kenya says thank you she's really
helpful
I'm glad I'm glad I could be of help and
you know feel free to ask anything or
you can direct message me on Twitter
whatever I ask it in the comments I'm
more than happy to help FCC jesse is
here just created okay cool
so is this so we have hash tag FCC jesse
sounds good that was created where are
we still talking about gator or IRC I'll
shoot it looks like the streams getting
terrible again so maybe this would be a
good time to wrap it up if the streams
the stream quality is going down
Oh on on freenode okay so so on freenode
there is now a channel that's FCC jesse
so FCC Jes si which I'm really flattered
that the channel has my name in it but
so yeah so if anybody is is still
listening which we actually have picked
up in viewers now it's I'm really
surprised that now after two hours we
picked up more viewers but not a lot of
years not as much as usual but um yeah
check it out on freenode channel FCC
Jesse and we keep the chat going and I'm
going to try to join in and just you
know this chat I definitely want to keep
it as a very very friendly place where
the criticism is gentle and
you know everybody tries to get along
not in like a false peace kind of
getting along like I'm definitely fine
with heated debates and things but I
just I'm not fine with people being mean
or rude so let's so let's all try to
keep it that way and keep it really open
and I think that'll be the best for
people who maybe are a little bit
nervous about speaking out and and
asking questions or things so yeah so if
you watch an hour if you hear this
recording and you want a place to go
you're a little bit nervous you know
check out that you know that channel on
freenode and you know you'll get you get
some some advice I you know I don't know
there's a lot of people in this chat now
they don't know what they're talking
about and I I know what I'm talking
about at least some of the time and so
I'll do my best to help out and I'm sure
they will too so awesome so I think this
was a really productive video I'm going
to wrap it up now because well we
accomplished what we wanted to
accomplish which was the load balancing
with the ssl pass-through we also went
over the wordpress api a little bit
which was requested so hopefully you all
got a little bit out of that and if you
want to see more about any of that stuff
let me know we also got a lot of good
advice on finding jobs and kind of
getting through that and now we have a
free node channel where we can chat even
outside the live chat so this is
probably you know with a really really
productive live chat sorry about the
poor quality and if you're watching this
video later on i'm sure it's not going
to be a great quality either probably
only like 480p replay quality so sorry
about that they're not all that quality
most of the other ones or are at least
1080p so I will be back on Monday at 2
p.m. I like vaguely remember that I
might have a meeting on Monday I do
have it on my calendar but I'll have to
check my email so if I have a meeting
during that 2:00 p.m. time period I will
make sure that I reschedule for a
different time that same day and I will
post that on Twitter to follow me on
Twitter if if you want to get that
update it will also be like they'll be
an update on the free code camp channel
so I think it will like pop up if you
have notifications enabled in your
browser or like on your phone so I so
hopefully I don't have a meeting and I
can do it as normal time but otherwise
I'll still do it I'll see you all on on
Monday and have a great weekend
you